Sometimes you want
to allow other people
to access your resources even
if they are from another origin.
This is mostly relevant
for API providers who
want other sites to be
able to use the service,
but the same-origin
policy prevents this.
Nowadays, you can easily achieve
this sharing of [? ratios ?]
with a set of AGB headers
called Cross Origin Resource
Sharing or CORS, for short.
This is the most powerful
engineering solution
to the single-origin problem.
But up until a few years ago,
the browser support for CORS
was rather lacking
and people had
to come up with
their own techniques
to work around the single-origin
policy in the meantime.
One of the oldest
techniques is called
JSONP, JSON with Padding.
Instead of simply
returning data,
JSONP returns a script
containing the data.
This exploits the fact that
the scripts from other origins
will execute and share
the execution environment
with your own scripts.
JSONP-based APIs expect to
include the function name
as a query parameter.
The server will return a new
script calling the function
that you named.
Let's look at a
fictional example.
Let's say we are building
an app at yourcourselist.com
that wants to list all the
university courses the user is
enrolled in.
The naive approach would
be to make a fetch request
to API, udacity.com and use
the return data to generate
a list for the user.
However, this will fail
with a security exception
as your host differs
from Udacity's host.
How would this API look
if it supports JSONP?
Add a function name to
the URL and include it
with a script tag.
The server will
wrap all the data
it needs to return in a function
call with the same name as
given via the query parameter.
You need to define this function
because when the response is
returned the function
call is executed
and you now have access to
the data for the parameter
of that function.